This is a American novel since 1945.
Welcome.
I'm Amy Hungerford today.
I'm going to do a couple of
things in the first half of class.
I'm going to tell you a little bit about
the class and introduce some of the
questions that we will
think about over the term.
If you stay in this course
in the second half of class,
I will introduce to you and start telling
the first story of the term and that's
about Richard Wright's black boy, which
is our first reading of the term, uh,
in between those two parts.
I will ask than anyone who is shopping
the class and would like to leave at that
time.
Do so then I would be grateful if you
would wait until that point if at all you
possibly can.
Uh,
just makes the whole thing work a little
easier and it prevents that drop in the
pit of my stomach when I see half
the class leave. So, um, I will,
I will indicate when that moment is,
come on,
make yourself comfortable on
the floor. Um, if you can.
My goal in this course is to allow you,
or to invite you to read some of the most
compelling novels written in the last
little over a half century.
This includes a whole
range of thematic concerns.
So when I looked down at my list of
novels, which I have not brought with me,
I trust you can find it on the web.
Um,
I didn't want to kill trees by making
enough of these for all of you.
When I looked down at my list of books
and I think about what these books are
about,
I see war,
I see war all the way from the Trojan
war to the Mexican American war in the
1840s,
all the way up to the Vietnam War.
I see love in all kinds of guises,
be they criminal as in Lolita,
pedophilia,
love be they uh,
sort of ideational romantic
John Barth be they campus love.
That's the human stain,
Philip Roth,
all kinds and forms of sex and love.
And then there's politics
interweaving with all those things.
There are questions of identity and race.
There is a nervous breakdown that actually
happens right here in new haven in
one of these novels that's
in Franny and Zooey.
I see women who give up on housekeeping
altogether and let their house go to
ruin and become vagrants. I
see suicide, I see slavery.
All these things you can
read about in these novels,
but reading these novels is not just
about reading about those things.
It's also going to be the process of
watching an artistic form unfold over a
very exciting period of time in the
second half of the 20th century and up now
into the 21st century writers,
we're thinking very hard about what to
do stylistically with all the innovations
that come in that powerful
period known as modernism.
So one of the things we're going to think
about together in the course is what
happens to all those innovations?
Are they abandoned?
Are they embellished or they
stretched or they rejected?
What happens to those resources that
the great modernist writers in Dowd
language with so powerfully
earlier in the century?
So there are formal questions that we
will take up time and again there are
questions that intersect between the form
and the content in every single novel
that we read.
Now perhaps those of you who like to
read fiction and especially who like to
read fiction from this period, we'll look
down at that syllabus and you'll say,
well where is,
where is your favorite writer?
Where is Don Delillo?
Where is John Updike?
My answer for the question
why these writers?
My answer for the question is the course.
It's an answer that unfolds over
these 14 weeks of the term 13,
13.
The short answer is that I think these
writers best represent all the different
threads,
all the different forces in American
novel since 1945 there are lots of other
writers we could include including those
two that I named that would equally
illustrate some of the threads that
I've got a on the syllabus now,
but these are the ones for
various practical and uh,
and more substantive
reasons that I have chosen.
Now you do have an opportunity this
class does that my class has never had
before.
And that is to nominate your own
novel for the last one that we read.
One of your choice.
Now I have done this in,
I did it in a sophomore seminar
and I did it in a graduate seminar.
I invited my students to,
uh,
present some choices to the class
and then the class voted on them. Uh,
it was incredibly successful in the,
in the undergraduate course.
It was a small seminar.
I had groups of students proposing
to novels actually for the end of the
syllabus.
And the exercise gets you to think very
hard about what you think this period is
all about.
It's not just about what's fun to read,
although it is that too.
Um,
it's about thinking what would make
the right ending to this intellectual
trajectory,
this intellectual narrative that
we're going to move through this,
this term,
what would make the right ending.
So it has a sort of
intellectual purpose to it. Um,
but I will tell you the students I had
in that seminar did amazing things to
push their choice of novel
for g one one group, um,
nominated Jeffery Jenny's Middlesex,
there was a huge art installation that
I walked into on that day of class.
It covered the ceiling and the
walls and the floors. It had,
they had done original photography
for it. It was really spectacular. Uh,
there was a, there was a theatrical
skit for Dave Eggers how we are hungry.
There was campaign literature,
um, pamphlets and so on.
So people were very creative with it
and it was really lots of fun. Um,
and for me it's,
it's fun because I may not know
the novel that you end up picking.
And so it is a kind of challenge for me
to take a novel that you've chosen and
come to grips with it myself.
It may be one that I know. Now,
let me just say in a,
in a technical way,
if you decide to volunteer
to nominate a novel,
you'll get no extra credit.
It will do nothing for your grade,
but you will get glory,
whatever glory there is to be
had at the front of this room.
Maybe that's like minuscule,
but maybe it's going to be fun for you,
especially if you have a
sort of theatrical bent or
if you like getting up in
front of people, uh, or
if you're just really,
really passionate about a novel
that you want everyone to read.
So that's something that we will do
and I will tell you more about at mid
semester. So that's the piece of the
syllabus that I can't tell you about.
I don't know what that,
what that a dream we're going to dream
together is when we read that novel.
I don't know what that'll be.
Um,
I want to just go over the
requirements of the course, uh, that,
that really are required,
not the optional piece. Um,
just so that you understand
what my purposes, um,
pedagogically this course is very much
open to English majors and to non English
majors. Uh, it's essentially
a reading course.
That's what I want you to take away from
this is the knowledge of these novels.
I want you to read them.
I want you to think about them.
I want you to talk about them.
Um,
but I don't expect you to
become an English major in
order to do that if you're
not already one.
However,
if you do happen to be an
English or literature major
or someone who's just very
serious about reading at that level,
you will find plenty to chew on here.
Not all of the novels aspire
to or have as their purpose.
That kind of difficulty that sometimes
English majors really want. They want to,
they want to have to work
incredibly hard at the formal level.
Some of the novels have that,
but not all of them.
The challenge for you is to figure out,
well what do we do with those novels?
What is the aim of a novel that
isn't all about formal innovation?
What are those novels doing?
Are they just like not a,
is it just inappropriate
to call them literature?
Should we think about
them in a different way?
How should we integrate that kind of
novel with novels that have more formally
ambitions?
So the paper length,
there are two papers required
and there's a final exam.
The paper length is
designed to be quite large.
It's a five to five to eight page papers.
Now a five page paper is very
different from an eight page paper.
If you're actually thinking about the
words you choose and how you write it.
If you just sort of, you know, the
night before scribble, scribble,
scribble until you're done.
Maybe there's not that much difference
between a five and an eight page paper
except like editing.
But substantively,
if you're using every
sentence in that paper,
you can write a lot more
in an eight page paper.
If you've used every sentence to say
something substantive to move an argument
along,
then you can in the five page.
That's for those people who really want
to push themselves and want to advance,
uh, really, uh, some significant
piece of thinking about a novel.
Now I will also say that
a five page paper written,
well can Trump an eight page paper
written poorly any day of the week.
So you don't have to write long papers.
But what I'm saying is the room
is there for you to stretch out.
If you want to do that.
Um,
the final exam you should do well if you
read and if you come to lecture and if
you 10 section the process
of doing those three things,
we'll have allowed you to already have
thought quite a bit about these novels.
You should remember them.
I think they're quite memorable.
They're quite distinct from each other.
Uh,
and you should be able to
manage with that final exam. Um,
without undue difficulty.
I will say that the reading load is heavy.
I've made some adjustments every year.
I'm trying to deal with the fact that
there are so many novels I love written
between say 1985 and the present
that are over 400 pages of piece.
So what do you do with
those on a syllabus? Well,
I guess it's the problem that the eight
people who teach the 18th century novel
always have, or the Victorian novel
Victorian novel, like the Triple Decker.
You know, the three volume
novel, least I don't have those.
But what I've is to excerpt some of the
texts earlier in the term and actually
there's a slightly heavier
reading before break, um,
than there used to be so that it's a
little bit lighter after break when we're
doing those long novels.
Okay. Last thing. Um,
this course, uh, as you may
have noticed from our, uh,
our friends behind us, uh, is
being filmed as part of the Yale,
the Open Yale courses, uh, initiative.
It is an initiative funded by the
William and Flora Hewlett Foundation.
This is one of eight courses being
offered this year that are, um,
that are being videotaped.
They will be made available free
to the public via the Internet.
So this is a way of allowing the world
to benefit from what we all do at Yale.
Um, that said, what we try to do,
what I will try to do and,
and what I hope you will try
to do is to forget about them.
It's sometimes hard for me, but I
trust that you will be able to do that.
Um,
so forget about that.
The point is not to cater to that camera,
but to do what we do and to show
the world what it is that we do.
Now I like to ask questions in lecture.
I really am just not a fan
of the sort of zone out,
a model of lecture audition.
So I will ask you questions.
The only annoying thing I will have
to do is to repeat your answers.
So I hope you will not object to that
because you don't have microphones on you
and it's very cumbersome to get them
back to you. So we're not gonna. Uh,
Mike, you said that your, your
answers can be hurt. All right. Uh,
any questions so far about what I've said?
Okay.
Now I want to talk about the handout.
Um,
those of you who don't have it,
there are a couple more up front here.
Uh, there should be the rest of the stack
over here. Oh No. These are my notes.
Uh, are we out? Yeah, there are a
couple more. And if you don't have one,
you can share.
What I have here for us
to look at together today
are two little texts.
I'm going to read parts of them to you
and together I think they give you the
sort of snapshot I want you to
have of where literature stands,
where reading stands at the Begin,
at the middle of the 20th century.
The first one is an advertisement for
the random addition of James Joyce's
Ulysses and this appeared in the
Saturday review of literature, uh,
in 1934.
So I'm going to read just parts and I'm
going to skip around a little bit and
stop and start
how to enjoy James Joyce's
great novel Ulysses.
Yes,
for those who are already engrossed in
the reading of Ulysses as well as for
those who has attained to begin it
because they fear that it is obscure.
The publishers offer this simple clue as
to what the critical fuss is all about.
Ulysses is no harder to understand
than any other great classic.
It is essentially a story
and can be enjoyed as such.
Do not let the critics confuse you.
Ulysses is not difficult to read and it
richly rewarded each reader in wisdom
and pleasure.
So thrilling and adventure into the
soul and mind and heart of man has never
before been charted.
This is your opportunity to begin the
exploration of one of the greatest novels
of our time.
What I want you to notice first of all,
is the kind of reader that's being
invoked here for that modernist classic
Ulysses.
It is not the fussing critic. Now, if you,
if you read down, if you sort of skimmed
down, you'll see that kind of language,
uh, applied to critics. They, uh, they,
they seem fretful.
They seem interested in obscure knowledge.
That's how this advertisement
represents critics. Even though,
even though it also invokes critics to
describe what's powerful about the novel.
So there's a sort of two faced
representation of the critic.
But the important one I think
is that dismissal of the critic.
The point of this advertisement is to
make you feel like you don't have to know
what the critic knows in
order to read this novel.
What you need is something
like strength or bravery.
Listen to that language.
For those who are already engrossed in
the reading of Ulysses as well as for
those who has a Tate to begin at.
The people already engrossed
are the strong ones.
And you can be that this are, this, uh,
advertisement wants to say you can be
the strong reader that hesitation those
who hesitate to begin at.
It's a kind of feminized
mincing approach to the novel.
It's sort of like those
fussy critics. So this, uh,
this advertisement tells you that the
great classic of Modernism is something
you stride into like a man,
but,
but you don't have to be a
particularly extraordinary man to do.
So.
This monumental novel about 20 hours in
the life of an average man can be red
and appreciated like any other great
novel once its framework and former
visualized,
just as we can enjoy hamlet without
solving all the problems which agitate the
critics and scholars. There's that
agitation that I was talking about.
The average man.
This advertisement wants you to see you
lyses as a story about a man you can
identify with.
So you don't have to be a critic,
you have to be strong.
But you know what,
you can be the average man because this
is a story about the average man with a
plot furnished by homer against a setting
by Dante and with characters motivated
by Shakespeare.
Ulysses is really not as difficult to
comprehend as critics like to pretend.
This is like saying dress,
buy Prada shoes by Ferragamo.
It's as if there are brands,
Dante, Shakespeare, homer,
that are identifiable.
They're familiar and what's
more they carry with it.
That sense of cultural capital. Well,
what do I mean by cultural capital?
It's that knowledge that makes you
one of the elite of your world.
It's also that knowledge that an educated
sort of Bella touristic reader of the
Saturday review of literature
would be very, very familiar with.
So in a sense it tells you this work of
art is of a piece with what you already
know. It's familiar in those ways
and you shouldn't be afraid of it.
At the same time,
it's part and parcel of that
elite body of knowledge.
So again,
there's this kind of two faced
newness to the advertisement.
It's both every man and it's the
elite who will best read this book.
Now I want to contrast that
with what we see from nobach off
in this essay.
Good readers and good writers.
This is from 1950
now the part of the essay just
prior to this explains that he gave,
he gave this little quiz that you see
to some college students when he was
giving a lecture,
so this is what he asked them to do.
Select for answers to the question,
what should the reader
be to be a good reader?
The readers belong to a book club.
The readers should identify himself
or herself with the hero or heroine.
The readers should concentrate
on the social economic angle.
The readers should prefer a story with
action and dialogue to one with none.
The readers should have
seen the book in a movie.
The readers should be a budding author.
The reader should have imagination.
The reader should have memory.
The readers should have a dictionary.
The reader should have
some artistic sense,
and a backoff says the student's leaned
heavily on emotional identification
action and the social,
economic and historical angle.
Of course,
as you have guessed,
the good reader is the one
who has imagination, memory,
a dictionary and some artistic sense,
which sense I proposed to develop in
myself and others whenever I have the
chance.
There are at least two varieties of
imagination in the reader's case.
So let us see which of the two is the
right one to use. In reading a book.
First there is the
comparatively lowly kind,
which turns for support to the simple
emotions and is of a definitely personal
nature.
A situation in a book is intensely felt
because it reminds us of something that
happened to us or to someone
we know or knew or again,
the reader treasures of book mainly
because it evokes a country, a landscape,
uh,
mode of living,
which he nostalgically recalls
as part of his own past or,
and this is the worst
thing or reader can do.
He identifies himself with
a character in the book.
This lowly variety is not the kind of
imagination I would like readers to use.
What a crime. How many of you are
guilty of this kind of reading ever?
Okay, now back off, be gone.
But he wants to get at something here and
I think it's helpful to put it next to
that advertisement for Ulysses.
He wants you to think
about reading on his terms.
His terms are very much informed by a
modernist sensibility of what literature
is all about.
And I'm going to say more about what
that is when I lecture on Lolita,
but it's very much in contrast with
that Ulysses ad don't identify.
It's not about you,
it's about something else.
But what is it about?
So what is the authentic instrument
to be used by the reader?
Is it,
sorry?
It is impersonal imagination
and artistic delight.
What should be established,
I think is an artistic,
harmonious balance between the
reader's mind and the author's mind.
We are to remain a little aloof and take
pleasure in this aloofness while at the
same time we keenly enjoy,
enjoy with tears and shivers.
The inner weave of a given masterpiece
to be quite objective in this matters is
a matter is of course impossible.
Everything thing that is worthwhile
is to some extent subjective.
For instance,
you sitting there may be merely my
dream and I may be your nightmare.
Some of you might think
that after a Lolita,
but what I mean is that the reader must
know when and where to contribute his
imagination and this he does by trying
to get clear the specific world,
the author places at his disposal.
If there's a balance of power between
the writer and the reader in this little
Vignette,
the power really I think
finally resides with the writer.
It is the writer who's world the
reader is here asked to get clear.
You are asked to use your imagination
to enter a world made by the writer,
a world of imagination and so it's the
writer who directs you in that way.
You are not asked to imagine a place
you knew something from your history,
something from your knowledge of yourself.
It is not about finding the average man,
which you are also in the novel
there staring back at you.
It's about finding some other dream world.
Maybe it's a nightmare world.
So for Nepal cough,
he wants to imagine a kind of literary
encounter that's very much separate from
those other things. He talks
about. Um, other media,
the movies, having seen
the book in the movie, uh,
from the life that we all lead when
we work and when we go to school,
the social economic angle,
he wants to read it as a
part from the emotions,
although he wants to enlist those
emotions in a very specific way.
Remember those tiers and shivers.
Those have to be the tiers
and shivers of impersonality.
That word impersonality made famous by
t s Elliott who advocated impersonality
as the ultimate stance of the artist.
That is the stance from which
all great art should proceed.
So nabar cough imbues that
state of impersonality with
certain kinds of emotion
and then asks the reader
to be as impersonal as that
modernist artists also must
be.
So what I think we'd get from these two
little readings today is this sense of
where literature finds itself
at a kind of crossroads.
What kind of reader our writers in this
period looking for and what do they want
from that reader? To what context
did they address themselves?
Is it a social context? Is it a
literary one? Is it a psychological one?
Is it a philosophical
cold one?
Is it a political one?
What should the novel strive to do?
What can novels do in the world?
What is the role of the imagination?
How does that factor in to what the,
the reader lives in,
in daily reality?
What is the status of identification?
Is that the primary model of readership?
Is that what makes people want to read?
Is that what should make
people want to read?
These are some of the
questions that these,
these two readings res and there are
questions that we will return to over and
over throughout the term.
Now I'm going to stop there.
I've gone on longer than I expected.
I'm going to let shoppers leave and
then I'm going to, in a very short time,
I'm going to,
uh,
pick up again and talk about Richard
Wright's so anyone who wants to leave now,
please do so
and please sign in. By the
way, guys, before you leave,
the sheets are coming. Round three.
Should I say you can sign in right there.
Oh, there's assignment chief. Thanks.
Those were my notes. Yeah, I
don't take those right here.
I was looking for the
Oh, syllabus, that sheet that was
handed out. Oh, uh, let's see.
Do I have any more online? No,
it's not. Hey Casey. Casey,
can I borrow your handout? Um, can he
have it? I'll give you another one.
[inaudible]
okay, I'm going to start even
though it's still in flux here,
cause I don't want to lose my time.
[inaudible]
Ooh, that's bad. Whoa,
I'm stepping over you.
I'm so sorry. Thank you.
All right. That was dramatic,
wasn't it? Um, okay.
All right. Now. Now we've talked about
the imagination. Now I want you to use it.
Now. I want you to use it.
Imagine that you are a,
it's all you've ever wanted to be.
You're at a very happy time in your life.
You just wrote a really successful novel.
Everyone loved it. It was unlike
anything that had been written before.
It was very well received.
You decided for my next project,
I am going to write about my life.
You've had a hard life by the way.
Uh,
you've had a hard life.
That hard life you think is really
what made you into the writer.
You are,
it's what allowed you to speak so
powerfully to people in your first novel.
And you've always wanted to write an
autobiography. So, so that's what you do.
That's what you take up
as your next project.
So you write the story
of your life. It's, uh,
nearly 400 pages long.
It gets a really nice reception
at a very good publisher.
It's in page proofs, everything's
going great, you're thrilled.
And then someone says to you,
you know,
imagine this is Oprah.
Oprah gets page proofs of your novel.
She's thinking about
putting it on her book club.
And if any of you know anything
about contemporary literature,
getting on Oprah's book club is like,
it makes your sales for the next
20 years. It's huge. It's huge.
There is no more powerful marketing force
in contemporary fiction than Oprah's
book club.
It even does wonders for Tolstoy when
Tolstoy gets on Oprah's book club. Um,
not by seance.
Um,
so you get on Oprah because Oprah
asked for the proofs for your novel.
She takes them, she says, this
is great, but you know what?
I think that last hundred pages you
should just get rid of it and you think
about it and you say yes,
and it comes out in that form.
And there you are.
And for the next 40 years,
no one ever sees the novel that you
wrote or the autobiography that you wrote
originally. It's still only two thirds
of what you ever wrote it to be.
Well, this is what
happened to Richard, right?
This is pretty much exactly what happened
to Richard Wright in 1944 so he had
published native son
in 1942 great acclaim,
very successful novel.
In 1944 he completed black boy
then called American hunger,
and he had placed it with
Harper and brothers publishing
company in New York and
they were very happy with them.
It had a first part called southern night
and a second called the horror and the
glory southern night was about his
experience growing up in Mississippi.
So he was born in 1908 and Mississippi.
And in 1927,
I think it's 27,
let me get my deep right.
In 1927, he moved to Chicago, moved north.
And uh,
in the 1940s,
he moved to Paris and
he died there in 1960.
So his was a progression out of a very
poor southern childhood from a black
family led by a single mother
to the circles in which
Gertrude Stein moved in Paris.
So this was a long trajectory,
well,
black boy or American hunger as it
was then called covered the part in
Mississippi and then the
beginnings of his life in Chicago.
Now the part about his life in Chicago
was the part that was finally cut from
the, not from the, I'm
going to keep doing this,
call it the novel versus
the autobiography.
And I'll explain why I made
that mistake a little later. Um,
it was cut from the autobiography.
Now he had this in page proofs with
Harper and brothers and heartburn brothers
sent the page proofs out to various
writers for blurbs and also sent it to the
book of the Month Club editorial board.
The book of the month club was a mail
order book club that started in 1926 and
it became an incredibly powerful
engine for selling books.
Just as Oprah's book club is today.
In 1926 it had about 4,700 members.
Just three years later,
it had 110,000 members,
110,000 subscribers in 1929 by the
forties and fifties it was incredibly
powerful.
So what we have is this marketing
juggernaut getting interested in Wright's
autobiography.
So they take it up and the board decides
that they only like the southern night
part. They don't want any of the part
of the story of his life in Chicago.
And that's what he finally agrees to.
So in the summer of 1944,
he embarks on this correspondence with a
woman named Dorothy Canfield Fisher who
was one of the editorial board
of the book of the month club.
And they go back and forth
trying to figure out how he
will revise the ending to
southern nights so that it sounds like
the end of the book rather than the end
of a section of a longer book.
Now for um,
for Wednesday I'm going to ask you to
go online to the Beinecke key digital
archive and read those letters.
We hold them here.
They are not published anywhere.
So this is kind of fun.
This is one of the special things about
being at Yale. We have those letters,
you can go and touch them.
Uh,
you can read them online and I want you
to read those in addition to reading, uh,
the sections that I've indicated.
Um,
you can see what happens when right
starts coming up against these demands on
his manuscript.
And I will project them during class too
so that we can, we can talk about them.
Rights manuscript was therefore very
much under pressure as a literary object,
and it really was a literary object.
I think we can make the mistake
thinking about autobiography,
that it's somehow not literary,
but in fact it's very literary.
And part of what makes it literary is
the fact that you have to choose what
scenes go into that narrative.
You can't just write every single
thing that happened in your life.
You have to choose.
Well,
critics took it fairly straightforwardly
as the account of a life,
and in that sense,
taking it that way,
some of them were a little disappointed
with what they held in their hands.
For one thing,
it seemed exaggerated to some people.
So the first scene as you'll discover
in black boy is when Richard Young
Richard,
he's like six burns down the family
house playing with matches underneath the
curtains,
and his mother finds him where he has
hidden under the burning house and flogs
him until he's unconscious and he's
sick for a good long time after that.
Okay. Critics were like, mm, I don't
think so. That doesn't seem right.
A mother flogs her son,
until he's unconscious,
didn't seem too credible.
As time went on,
there were other kinds of
complaints these about accuracy.
So for instance,
his mother in the book is
represented as being uneducated.
Well, in fact, she was a school teacher.
Now there is a difference between scholars
on how long she was a school teacher.
Some say she was a sort of
long term successful school
teacher. Others said, well,
she only taught school for a
couple of months. So this was not,
didn't seem to be accurate.
Then there was another scene in,
in the autobiography where Richard,
who was the Valedictorian of
his high school class, um,
writes his valedictory speech gives it
as required to the principal beforehand.
The principal demands certain kinds
of changes and Richard refuses.
Well, apparently Richard in
real life, did not refuse.
Make those changes and imagine in a
book that then undergoes this publishing
history that I've described this,
this is kind of a symbolic scene.
This is a scene of whether you as a
writer compromise yourself in the face of
authority that resists what you
want to say. So in the book,
it's a very important scene.
It's the moment when Richard
really finds his voice and get it,
gives him the strength eventually
to leave the south. But,
uh, in real life, apparently he did cave.
Yeah.
Then there came to be questions
about whether the scenes,
the stories in the book
actually did happen to him.
So there's this story about his uncle
Hoskins who takes his horse and cart with
Richard in the back and drives it into
the middle of the Mississippi River as a
kind of practical joke on Richard.
Well,
apparently this is not something
that happened to Richard, right.
This is something that
happened to Ralph Ellison.
Yeah.
Where these stories come from,
began to be a problem.
So what his autobiography,
what is this Shondra that
right is working with, um,
it raised these kinds of
questions on the one hand,
but then there was another
kind of question and uh,
that was coming from the
other side. This is what, uh,
William Faulkner wrote to
write upon reading black boy.
He said,
the good lasting stuff comes out of one's
individual imagination and sensitivity
to and comprehension of the
sufferings of every man.
Any man not out of the
memory of one's own grief.
I hope you will keep on saying it,
but I hope you will say it.
As an artist,
as in native son.
So Faulkner's objection
is on the other side.
It's not fictional enough to write about
your life and to pretend that you're
communicating the memory of what
happened to you. Your grief,
your private grief doesn't
contain that universalizing move,
that fiction by its very essence
contains and you see that.
You know, you can remember back to that
conception of literature we see in the
advertisement for Ulysses,
that it's about every man that great
greatness in literature comes from its
ability to speak to some
archetypal every man, any man.
And Faulkner capitalizes those,
those words in his letter as
if they really are types well,
right himself described that difficulty
of writing his autobiography and this,
this, this is, these
are the terms he used.
I found that to tell truth is
the hardest thing on earth.
Harder than fighting in a war harder
than taking part in a revolution.
If you try it, you will find that
a time sweat will break upon you.
You will find that even if you succeed
in discounting the attitudes of others to
you and your life, you must
wrestle with yourself. Most of all,
fight with yourself for there will
surge up in you a strong desire to alter
facts,
to dress up your feelings.
You'll find that there are many things
you don't want to admit about yourself
and others as your record shapes itself.
An odd wonder haunts you,
and yet there is no more exciting and
adventure than trying to be honest in this
way.
The clean,
strong feeling that sweeps you when
you've done it makes you know that.
And even though,
and that little passage,
he suggests that it's a
struggle to be truthful,
a struggle to be accurate,
a struggle not to dress up your feelings
with some sort of embellishment.
He at other times says that,
well,
some of the stories did
come from other people.
Some of the stories he included did
come from other people's experiences,
not from his own life.
And that this is allowed and allowable
because what he aimed to do was produce a
generic life of a black
boy living in the south.
And from the titles we know
he considered for this book,
none of them make that claim.
The life of Richard, right?
None of them say that it's
always black boy American hunger.
These are not person specific.
These implicitly make a claim to the
generality at the national scale or in the
racial sense,
the representativeness of this life and
indeed what more powerful testimony to
the power of narration is there the
power of a story to say that you heard a
story and it became as if part of your
experience that you heard Ralph Ellison
tell that story and somehow
you began to live it yourself.
So what we see in the publishing history
of black boy and also in its reception
brings us back to those questions that
I was raising at the beginning of class.
What is the relationship
between writing in the world?
What's the relationship between
the writer and the reader?
What's the relationship between fiction
and what we all experience as the real
world?
Our course over the term,
we'll come back to this question over
and over again and it will also come back
to the generic question of autobiography.
Uh,
even so experimental,
a book as a John Barth lost in the fun
house is totally absorbed in the problem
of what it would mean
to write about yourself.
It's a persistent problem,
partly because it always raises these
issues of fictional reality versus
truthfulness of honesty
versus embellishment.
It also raises the question
of how a self is made.
If we look forward to the end of the term,
when we read the human stain,
which is about a man Coleman
silk who tries to weld,
tries to and succeeds
in passing as Jewish,
he's a black man and he passes for his
whole life as Jewish and in doing so,
reject his family.
Okay?
In a way,
what Komen does is write his autobiography
of fictional autobiography in the
very process of living it.
So Roth imagines lived life as fictional
in the same register as a novel or as
truthful dubiously stow perhaps in
the same register as an autobiography.
So these are questions
that we'll come back to us.
This is part of what I find so compelling
about fiction and literature in
general in this period. And this is
why I study it. This is why I teach it,
because that interface between the
imagination and the world between literary
art and trying to tell the truth about
something between form and content,
those contexts are very,
very close and they're very compelling.
And I think in part because other media
are so powerfully on the rise in this
period,
literature has to figure out
where to stake its claim.
What can literature say
that nothing else can?
How can it address us in a way that is
compelling in a way that nothing else is?
Can we make those kinds
of claims for literature?
The writers on the syllabus consistently
try to imagine a way to make those
claims, make those claims for the primacy
and the importance of what they do.
And I think that in addition to being
able simply to understand the literature
of your moment,
to understand the literary world in
which writers probably among you sitting
right here,
that world in which you will
bring forth your next novel,
what that world looks like,
you can understand that world,
but also you can understand how art
confronts the world in a much more general
sense.
That's what's exciting,
and that's what I invite you to think
about with me in the course. Um,
so I'll stop there and hopefully
I'll see some of you on Wednesday.